mes prédécesseurs était formidable au
fond on m'a dit de regarder la montre il
faut pas que je parle trop
je pourrais seulement dire qu'elle y
aviez ouzbeks en ouzbékistan m'a dit un
jour qu'on parlait toujours de ce qu'on
n'avait pas on est crevé de faim on
parlait de la nourriture donc si on m'a
demandé parler de la paix c'est qu'il ya
un problème savez j'ai remarqué je vous
recommande un livre qui vous connaissait
certainement qu'on n'avait pas lu la
bible
peut-être certains des plus beaux livres
que jamais été écrit il ya deux mots qui
se répètent constamment 168 voix
zarour souviens toi et 154 x shalom la
paix je me suis demandé quelle est la
relation entre ces deux mots ce qu'est
pour demander la paix il faut peut-être
savoir à quoi on arrive si la paix
n'existait pas souviens toi on a vu des
photos
j'essaie de mort 1 souviens-toi ensuite
souviens-toi hiroshima souviens toi ce
qui se passait en
avec les tutsis massacrés à la hachette
par les hutus souviens toi et du coup on
s'est donc comme objectif d éviter la
répétition de tous à la vie c'est une
vie qu'elle soir que la personne qui
meurt soit noir blanc jaune peu importe
le cadavre d'un cadavre
donc vous ne pas répéter cela pour ne
pas voir cela il faut la paix
c'est un désir il ya un homme qui se
délite la désirait il a terminé sur la
croix ça marche pas c'est pas si simple
parler de la paix j'ai essayé de faire
ce que je pouvais je me suis rendu
compte qu'il d'abord pour parler de la
paix il faut expliquer tout ça aux gens
qui ne comprennent pas son importance
il faut comprendre qu'ils celui qui est
en face de nous invite à parler
d'égalité parfaitement nous sommes tous
égaux
mais comme dit shakespeare dans jules
césar et un très beau dialogue entre et
brutus et art brut us dis 'assez' à
césar césar nous sommes tous égaux
l'autre répond ne sont pas tous pareils
pour faire la paire de clotile faut
savoir qui ce n'est pas seulement moi
dans un miroir il a aussi une histoire
il a ses souvenirs et par rapport à ses
souvenirs sa mémoire
il réagit pas exactement comme moi sont
tous égaux nous avons tous droit à la
vie vous raconter une petite histoire
j'ai essayé de faire la paix entre
israéliens les palestiniens n'a pas les
signes étaient là je connais à ramallah
avant qu'elles qu'elles naissent elle
c'est formidable ce qu'elle fait et un
jour mon éditeur m'a appelé m'a dit
écoute tu connais arafat vous êtes très
amis et pourquoi est ce que tu lui
demanderais pas un livre biographie donc
j'ai appelé arafat et dia soeur voilà
mon éditeur voudrait avoir ta biographie
je suis pas là pour écrire des livres je
suis là pour libérer mon tacle mais bon
si tu as quelqu'un qui veut faire un
entretien avec moi je vais bien et tu
corriges donc j'ai appelé des amis une
journaliste palestinienne qui s'appelait
raimondas tawil ramanda tawil m'a dit
prends ma fille sura je suis parti avec
sa fille zohra
à l'époque l'ol belle se trouvait près
de tunis
je le vois il y avait des gens avec des
kalachnikovs pour protéger faut dire
qu'ils n'ont jamais écrit un livre sont
mariés je suis le parrain de leur fille
tout juif que je suis né dans le ghetto
de varsovie à un moment donné on était
des tables à rabat ne dorme agit presque
jamais donc ils donnaient des
rendez-vous la nuit il buvait du thé et
ils mangeaient des raisins secs elle
partageait il ya un moment donné on lui
apporte un télégramme il essaie de lire
il n'arrive pas une sorte de lunettes il
dit you see my friends
heinig culasse et snam j'ai besoin de
lunettes
une semaine après je suis à jérusalem
j'ai notre famille shimon peres pour le
shabbat vendredi soir avec sa femme
sonia d un moment donné perez m'a dit
alors comment va ton ami le palestinien
jeudi vieilli commence à yviers et je
lui raconte l'histoire de lunettes
j'ai senti qu'en ce moment là d'un seul
coup shimon peres a compris qu'ils ont
face il y avait un nom ce n'est pas un
ennemi step est un ennemi qui pouvaient
poser des bombes pour dix terrains y
avait un nom il vieillissait comme lui
il avait besoin d'elle une
il s'est humanisé aussi trois mois après
ils sont rencontrés chez moi à paris lé
processus des paix ce qu'on appelle
stockholm s'est mis en marche
il aboutit sauf qui héritera cabine a
été tué par un extrémiste
j'ai pleuré c'est tout ce que je pouvais
faire comme sadate qui a été tué aussi
pas extrêmement la lutte pour la paix
c'est un ré commencement perpétuelle nos
pulsions de mort disait freud sont
beaucoup plus forts que nous puissions
des vies on est en face de quelqu'un ils
nous empêchent d'avancer on lui parle
pas on n'a pas le temps ou les frappes
si on parlait si on apprenait à parler à
l'autre
mais pour cela il vaut déjà s'intéresser
à l'autre qu'ils en fassent des toits
qui empêchent d'avancer dit donc pas la
peine il ya un garçon théo qui est venu
me chercher à la gare je lui ai expliqué
s quai avant de venir me chercher à la
gare est ce que vous avez regardé dans
google qui j'étais ce simple aujourd'hui
les informations marche formidable
longue date l'ap et on voit qu'ils et
c'est lui qui vous allez chercher à la
gare c'est tellement important sabah qui
est en face de tellement important et
savoir qu'ils n'aient pas les mêmes que
nous savions quand david a montré les
très beaux textes
il ya deux siècles d'une révolutionnaire
il parle d'égalité
oui nous sommes tous égaux nous avons
tous les mêmes droits
mais chacun de nous a une histoire et on
peut pas faire la paix si on connaît pas
l'histoire de l'autre peut pas faire
l'appel
la n10 montagne vient de l'ignorance
nous avons un voisin il a une des
traditions différentes
la cuisine qu'il fait à des odeurs ses
skis chirac appelle un jour vous vous
souvenez spatiaux solennel il est allé
visiter un site et il est gentil
chirac dit je comprends qu'on pète
indisposés par les odeurs d'une cuisine
qui n'est pas la nôtre
oui moi j'aime bien le football il
fallait s'y intéresser des gens que tu
vas voir robert bilié bi tribune ivry
sur seine ont des traditions culinaires
si on partageait la transition les
chemins de la paix ce ne sont pas des
chemins droits iront on a on a une
boussole lyon n'avance pas du tout en
interdisant il ya chaque étape on se
heurte à quelqu'un qui a une autre
histoire
l'histoire l'a dit notre ami le
photographe journaliste a raconté de cet
enfant qui a dit je t'ai dénoncerait
adieu magnifique quelqu'un d'autre
aurait dit autre chose ce n'est pas
universelle la vie est universel mais
elle aime ultime tome 1 17 milliard
d'individus 7 milliards de mémoire vous
rendez compte
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour l'est
pas s'y fier pour la mettre ensemble
pour le faire accepter très très dur
très dur
regardez l'histoire de l'humanité les
plages de l'apple app les places en
guerre sont très court très court on
passe d'une guerre à l'autre d'une gare
alors on arrête ici que ça commence
ailleurs c'est dur
c'est pour ça qu'ils m'ont demandé de
parler de la paix il faut pas le fallait
pas dépasser 18 minutes
moi j'ai déjà terminé dix minutes 26
cette fille là palestiniens cette
extraordinaire elle a dit une chose qui
est important dans la région d'athènes
les rôles de la femme dans dans la
civilisation dans la société musulmane
la femme n'a pas beaucoup de place chez
nous non plus ne seyait on a introduit
la parité les jours où la femme commence
à prendre le pouvoir
tout change regardez ce qui se passait à
belfast sais pas si vous vous souvenez
la guerre en irlande le protestant
contre les catholiques il s'est découpé
en morceaux
la plainte des films sur liera à les
terroristes irlandais et puis un jour je
suis allé à plusieurs reprises un ami
kouchner on essaie de parler de voir les
uns les autres à ne pas marcher
de quoi vous mêler et puis un jour
quatre femmes de protestants des
catholiques on dit c'est assez on a
perdu nos enfants et on va pas continuer
comme ça ils ont fait ils ont fait appel
à toutes les femmes
dès décembre dans la rue je ne pouvait
que venir les soutenir
il y avait quelques hommes avec aussi
cinq cent mille femmes protestantes
catholiques on parle plus de belfast
orient mon rêve mon rêve c'est
d'organiser des femmes israéliennes et
palestiniennes
imaginez cette cette image jérusalem il
a au monde vers jérusalem
surtout qu'ils rosalen domine la mer
morte qui est 400 mètres au dessous des
niveaux de la mer donc paraît encore
plus haut imaginez de deux côtés
cent mille femmes palestiniens cent
mille femmes israël yak
monde vers j'osais je vous garantis
après il y aura plus de guerre mais il
faut qu'elles effacent c'est difficile
faire pour les autres les papes ce
qu'ils disaient c'est de l'or c'est vrai
faut que ça vient de l'intérieur époque
qu'on ressente la nécessité majeur jeu
paraît très souvent comme un donneur de
leçons d'ailleurs nous en france on est
toujours de leur donner leur sang on a
réussi pour dire à poutine qui ce n'est
pas bien au bayer pour dire sympa bien
ce terrain puis on oublie ce qui se
passait mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
autrement je suis en train d'organiser
avec des amis musulmans
la première marche mondiale de musulmans
contre le terrorisme on gagnera jamais
contre le terrorisme
ça doit venir de l'intérieur
il faut que les femmes musulmanes les
maris les grands parents disent aux
autres c'est pas le meilleur moyen c'est
pas les mêmes moyens
alors c'est dur d'organiser ça c'est dur
parce que je ne suis pas musulman
je pars musulmans je me souviens je
m'intéresse marc organiseront des vols
ben gourion
il était sur son lit de mort dans sa
dans son appartement jeudi rothschild à
tel aviv et à un moment donné je lui
demande on parle je demande david david
en hébreu il n'y a pas de vous on s'est
dit tu es david a vite
qu'est-ce que tu ferais à la place des
palestiniens et dans les dernières
souffle m'a dit mais marek je suis pas
mal estoniens on peut pas se mettre à la
place de l'autre on peut en pâtir
on n'est pas l'autre donc ce qu'on peut
faire c'est demander à l'autre de se
mettre en marche
je ne sais pas si cette marche que
j'organise ça n'a rien à voir avec la
marge de macron mais pourquoi pas s'il
veut marcher avec nous bienvenue on
partirait le 8 juillet de berlin devant
l'église où la terroriste d'origine
tunisienne a tué des innocents
on va prendre des autobus longue
caravane
lyon va faire le tour de tous les lieux
où on a tué au nom de l'islam elle ces
imams vont dire une prière dans mois
l'imam est on arrivé à paris les 14 juin
elle vous serez tout cela pour nous
accueillir
j'espère voyez je n'ai même pas arrivés
à 18 minutes un qui ait la paix soit
avec vous merci
[Applaudissements]